Speaker 1: It's great to welcome back to the
program today, David Sirota, who is a journalist,
columnist and founder and editor of The Lever,
which you can find at Lever News.com. It's been a
little while since since we had you on and you've
been busy, but it's really great to have you on.
Speaker 3: Thanks. Thanks.
Thanks so much for having me.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, let's just kind of
start start at the top here. What was the
goal with creating the lever? What are the
issues in the media landscape that you're
hoping to solve or improve upon or address?
Speaker 3: Sure. I mean, I had been working
for Bernie Sanders as his speechwriter on the
2020 presidential campaign, but before that,
I spent many years as a journalist. And after
the campaign, I decided to do some writing. And,
you know, I'd actually started out as a as just
a small substack, but there was a lot of reader
support for it. And so I teamed up with a former
reporter that I had formerly worked with, Andrew
Perez, to start doing some actual reporting.
And from there, it kind of grew. And and,
look, I think that what what our focus is, what
a lever story is, is a story that's about. It's
about following the money. It's about following
the power. Our our mission is to actually change
the conversation and change the policies in this
country so we don't pretend to just be, you know,
reporting whatever is going on. We our reporting
is accountability journalism designed to hold
politicians accountable when it comes to issues
that deal with money and power. So, for instance,
in the last month or so, we broke open the story
of the deregulatory decisions that were made on
rail safety in the lead up to the East Palestine,
Ohio derailment. We this week we spent a lot of
time breaking open stories about the regulatory
decisions that were made to deregulate Silicon
Valley Bank and what were the decisions made
by politicians for which donors. So we are
constantly asking the question, who are public
officials actually serving? We are constantly
spotlighting that. So with the idea that the
more that the readership knows, the more that
the readership can be engaged to actually pressure
their lawmakers to do to make better decisions.
Speaker 1: So how is this funded? Because one
of the interesting things is, particularly when
the focus is to follow the money and to have
accountability. My guess is you have to be
particularly careful about following the money
when it comes to your organization as well.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I mean, we're look, we're reader
supported. We work with other media outlets like
Jacobin as an example, syndicates our work some
some of our work appears in The Guardian. So
so we have a kind of I mean, we're small, right?
So we're trying to to build out. But we we are a
reader supported news organization that holds them
accountable, holds them being the proverbial them,
meaning corporations, politicians and the like.
And I think that what you'll see is, is that on
our stories, one thing that I'm really proud of on
our stories is I think when you read our stories,
you don't have to trust us, right? Because what we
do in every story and we take a lot of time to do
this is to link to all of the primary sources in
which we are referring to. So I say this all the
time. If you read one of our stories is all you
know. Sirota is this Sirota, is that, hey, listen,
that's fine. You can believe whatever you want
about me. The links to the source materials are
all there for you to evaluate. I fully believe in
in. I don't even believe in trust, but verify. I
believe first and foremost in verify. So when you
read one of our stories, when you see it linked
to all the that source material, that's because
we're trying to show the reader, hey, listen, if
you don't trust us about a statement, an assertion
that we make here, a statement of fact that we
make your go, makes you can go fact check us.
And we have a vigorous fact checking process in
what we do. But that's the point here, is that I
think that we a lot of ways we in media, the media
ecosystem has gotten away from that which has
created an environment in which people can say,
oh, that's, you know, quote unquote, fake news.
So the way we combat that is to try to present
all of our facts and be very open and transparent
about that so you can debate, you know, this or
that about the writer or about the publication,
but you can't debate the documents and facts.
Speaker 1: What are your thoughts on whether
there can be other. There are funding methods
for organizations like yours or mine or larger
media or whatever that you find journalistically
ethical or kosher or whatever word you might
want to apply to it in the sense of if there is
any kind of advertising. Is that necessarily
a problem or does it depend on the subject
matter that is being covered and the types of
products and services being advertised or like
what other models are okay in your mind?
Speaker 3: It's a great question. I mean,
to my mind I am look, I am we don't have corporate
ads, right, and the like, but I'm not a purist
when it comes to this. I'm not a purist when it
comes to foundation funding. I'm not a purist
when it comes to, you know, individual donors. I
think that we live in a world of unfortunately,
where getting resources to do public interest
journalism. There is no public funding for
that in any kind of institutional level.
There is in a sense of crowdsourcing it,
but that is a very, very tough, tough road. It's
a worthwhile road. We are on that road as a as an
as an entity. So it's hard for me to create, you
know, hard and fast rules other than to say this,
I think being reader supported at some capacity is
important, and having that be a major pillar of a
media organization is extremely important for many
reasons, one of which is you want to be serving
a readership and at least have that be a a huge
pillar of what you are, who you are answering to
for the resources to do journalism. I also think
that that that having reader support is actually
over the long haul, if you can do it, is actually
more stable in the sense of a lot of small,
comparatively small contributors becomes a more
stable funding base than one or two or three huge
funders or huge corporations that can wake up on
a on a given day and just pull funding. Right. So
I think there's a stability issue there. Yeah.
Speaker 1: One of the things about that that's
interesting, which I've talked with my audience
about, and I think most recently somewhere between
38 and 40% of our total revenue comes from direct
subscriptions from people in the sort of style
you're talking about is it's on the one hand of
it, Bob and Brenda can directly support the work
I'm doing rather than whoever else, corporate
entity or whatever on the other side of it,
because Bob and Brenda are just two people
who I love. Bob and Brenda are great. They're
also not going to be able to get me to
change what I'm doing with the threat
that they will pull their five bucks a month.
Speaker 3: That's that's absolutely right. I mean,
it's a kind of diversified portfolio model,
which is which is what I like. And maybe the
the the hard and fast rule is kind of
this is that if you have a diversified
funding base, resource base that is not singularly
reliant on any of the categories, that is, I think
the ideal I mean, the ideal ideal is to have it
be purely individual, small subscription based to
fund a giant newsroom. I don't think anybody has
been able to do that yet, and maybe we're on our
way to that. Who knows? But no one has as real
as to my mind has really been able to do exactly
that. So one level down from that is, okay, how
can I put together some major donors, foundations,
not nonprofit foundations, a subscription base,
so that so that the publication doesn't have to
singularly answer to any one of those entities
that's about as independent, I think. I mean,
that's pretty good. And again, I'm not I'm not
a purist on this. What I want to see I mean,
right now we live in a world, of course, that's
so far from pure. We live in a world where where
media is is dominated by huge corporate entities
with either, you know, singular billionaires at
the top of them, Bloomberg News and the like,
or massive corporations that are that are making
the decisions. Those are those aren't really
diversified at all. It's very clear who they
answer to. In fact, some of these publications
put right underneath the top of their articles
presented by Chevron right now, there's, you know,
I guess in some ways, kudos to them for at least
being transparent about that. But they're also
being explicit about who they actually serve. And
I think ultimately you can see the independence of
media by the content that the media is producing.
I go back to what we produce. I, I don't think.
Anybody could could read what we do and say, oh,
we go easy on this or that entity or this or that
faction of four for this or that reason. I mean,
we are trying to follow the money no matter
where it goes. And we have been critical of
the Progressive Caucus at times. We have obviously
been critical of the Republicans. At times we've
been critical of of corporate Democrats at
times. And when I say we've been critical,
what I mean is our reporting is holding them
accountable. It's not just us going out and
saying, you know, they're jerks or whatever.
It's us actually holding them accountable.
Speaker 1: And last thing on this, I think even
though we have a lack of media literacy in in some
senses in this country, a lot of media consumers
intuitively can tell the difference between when
Deepwater Horizon is going on. Anderson Cooper
goes to a break and there's a BP ad right on
the one hand. And then on the other hand in
an article that you do about the derailment,
there might be you recommending a shaving razor
or something like that. I think people would be
able to distinguish which one is potentially
directly related to the stories that are being
reported and how versus things that are not.
Speaker 3: That that look, that. That's absolutely
right. So so when people ask me, you know, would
you ever take, you know, advertising whichever,
you know, I'm like, well, would I ever take
advertising from Chevron? No. Right. Like,
like that's problematic. So but but I think
there's there's huge gradations. And I and
I really I want to reiterate this. I, I, I, I
truly don't think purity and I'm putting that
in quotes is a way to look at this. If we
want to build a healthy, independent media
in a country that does not offer institutional
public funding for media. Right. We're
going to have to try to find models and formulas
that allow us to do that and and where it doesn't
take 15 or 20 years to build out fully a an
individual subscriber base that can support a 100,
200 300 person newsroom like like climate change
is not waiting for us to to do that. And and look
I'm really proud of the of the reader support
that we have. I'm really encouraged by the
grassroots reader support that other independent
media like like your show like like other shows
have been able to generate in recent years. It
is a long, hard slog. It is inherently a long,
hard slog and we don't have time to wait.
Speaker 1: I was going to talk a little bit
about sourcing, but I think it might be more
interesting instead to get your thoughts about
nuance maybe is the way I would put it. You know,
one of the things that's really tough with stories
that are more complicated than the simplest of
simplest stories, which is really most of them,
is that oftentimes when you introduce nuance or
you revise your views, you are potentially accused
of either flip flopping or you were originally
lying or you're backpedaling or whatever the case
may be. This comes up a lot of times with messages
I get about COVID vaccines about. But but, David,
you said one thing in 2021 and now you're saying
something else. And you have to sort of explain,
well, listen, the vaccine in 2021, based on the
variant that was out there, was very effective at
preventing transmission and infection. The virus
that is out there has changed. The vaccines have
been updated and it is now more a tool for
preventing death and hospitalization and not
really a tool for preventing. Oh, so you're
backpedaling is how what's the best way for
people in my position or in your position to deal
with this? Bearing in mind that we always want
to be communicating the best information we have
at the time and we want to be completely honest,
but we also know that the appetite for nuance is
maybe more limited than we would like it to be.
Speaker 3: That's a great that's a really,
really great question. Well, first and foremost,
I think we have to understand that there is a
learning process that as we learn new information,
conclusions will change. I mean, that's that's
part of the human experience. Anybody who
who doesn't want to learn new information and
thus change conclusions is I mean, you're heading
straight into denialism, right? So I don't think
it's I don't think media should participate in
any kind of denialism at all. I think I think
the other point about this is to is actually to
what we try to do in our reporting. I always say
this to my reporters is to state what we know as a
fact right now. Yeah, don't foreclose on the idea
that the facts in the future can change, but also
don't say things that are not grounded in facts
that are that can't be verified. So, you know,
did ex lead to why did this deregulation lead
to this disaster? You can only really say that
if you can prove it, but you can say. These
senators or these lawmakers ignored warnings
about this outcome to cast votes for that kind of
deregulation. And then this happened right now.
So my point is, is that that's a nuance, but it's
an important point. As long as you're still saying
what can be factually verified, I think that's
the obligation. And I mean, that is the job of
journalism, is to say what we know to be true
without speculating or extrapolating. It's when
you get into extrapolating ahead in the future
that it becomes problematic, Then it can become
I mean, I hate this term, but then it can become
too susceptible to the charge of quote unquote,
fake news. Yeah, nothing is fake news if you're
stating in this document or on this day this thing
happened and you can pretend it didn't happened.
But that's like pretending the sky isn't blue.
That's, to me, the. The role of the journalist.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And to stick with the covered
examples, that was frequently it came up when
people would call me about hydroxychloroquine
or ivermectin or whatever. And it's I'm not
going to say this does not work. What I can
tell you is we don't have the type of evidence
now that medical science requires to say that
it works. Could that evidence be presented
in the future from a study that hasn't yet
been done? Sure. But, of course, again,
it's all about whether the audience you
have is receptive to that. And I think part of
hopefully what we are doing is cultivating such
an audience that understands those those nuances.
Speaker 3: Absolutely. And I think I think that's
actually part of I mean, there's kind of like what
we're doing on a day to day basis, reporting a
story on Silicon Valley Bank, reporting a story on
the decisions in the lead up to the East Palestine
disaster. But I think over the long haul, what
we're also doing, what independent media is doing,
is saying that media needs to go back,
not that everything was better before,
but there needs to be a reconnection with the
idea that media's job is to hold accountable those
of all parties without regard to party,
without regard to kind of tribal politics.
We're going to hold people accountable to
the facts as we know them now. And if the
facts change in the future or there's new facts
that arise, we're going to report on those, too.
Speaker 1: We've been speaking with David
Sirota, who's founder and editor of The
Lever. You can find more at Lever Newscom.
Always appreciate your time and insights.
Speaker 3: Thank you. Thanks
so much for having me.